よろしくお願いします
はい これから今日のテーマに沿ってお話をさせていただきます
あの 俗世間に対しての話です
在家信者さん向けの幸福論ということで
それ始まる前にちょっとした小話として
この仏教は数字が大好きなんですね
あの 全部数字でなんですよ
四聖諦やら八正道 五蘊ですね
七覚支 三十七菩提分法
百八十観覚はね まあ百八煩悩もありますけど
それから三つの渇愛 もう何でも何でも数字
数字 数字 数字で言ってるんです
なんでこんなに数字が好きでしょうかっていうね
数字でまとめるためにはデータをすべて揃える必要がありますよ
これ 何でも数字で言うのはそう簡単じゃないんです
何か何か これこれこれありますよと言うためには
そのすべてのデータを取ってないと
その数字で分けることは難しいんです
誰かがリストに一つでも足すと
前のリストは不完全であったことになるんです
例えば 真理は 真理は 4つありますとお釈迦様はおっしゃったんですけど
誰かが 5番目の真理を発見したならば
お釈迦様の教えは間違ったことになるんです
それでお釈迦様はデータ全て一切のデータを調べたく
調べてないということになるんです
だから数字で物事を言うのはかなり危険なものなんです
例えば 現代的な我々の研究やら全て
まあもう自分が自分の手に入ったデータから結論を出したり
論文を書いたりする それで次の研究者が新しいデータを見つけたら
また前のものは変わったりするんです
科学というよりも医学なんですね
もうもう 1ヶ月とか 2ヶ月間経ってくると
また全部変わっていて
薬も何でもかんでも で
数字で丸めるでしたっけ
うん 小学者 ブッダには簡単にできる
だから世の中で一番難しいことですよ
この数字で言うのは お釈迦様はこれなんか自分の特色みたいね
仏教はとにかく数字が好きなんです
何でも数字で言うんです
それでこの長部経典の最後にあるサーリプッタ尊者の経典がありまして
アヌパナスッティ経典ですけど
そちらにこの全部どのように数字でまとめておくのかというブッダの教えをね
もうそういうふうにまとめているんです
で アビダンマ論というものがございまして
とにかく数字 一つにカテゴライズできる法
2つに分けられる法  3つに分けられるもの
もう 4つ  8つ もうそういうふうにもう数字を先に出すのです
だから この数字を先に出すっていうことは
言っていることは完全なものであるという挑戦なんです
一般の世間に対してかなりの挑戦なんです
できれば変えなさいよと
お釈迦様はそういう感じで
私は真理4つあるんだよと言ったんだよと 5
番目はないんだと だから
そういうふうにも大胆に言えるためには
やっぱり初学者で偏狭でなければできません
だから一つ 仏教は他の宗教と比較すると
もうものすごい もう何といいますか
もう断言的に言うんです
何も怖いものはないという感じで
そういうことで この仏教は数字にこだわっているということがあるんです
その中で数字を使ういろいろな複雑なやり方とかたくさんありますけど
今日はそんなことを話しちゃうと
今日のテーマができなくなりますからね
また 私たちに大事なポイントを忘れることがなく
覚えたり実践したりすることができるんですね
で 数字であると一番便利なところは覚えやすいんです
誰かが人がアドバイスくれたりする
それでお釈迦様があなたにね
3つ教えてあげますよ
この 3つ回りなさいというと
本人が3つ教えたんだから
帰る途中で何か忘れたらそれわかるんですよ
私は忘れてるんだと 一部は数字で言わないと
自分覚えたものだけ これこそ正しいんだ
これこそ仏説やとか言い張ったりするんですよ
その間違いは起こりません
例えば お釈迦様が 8つの項目を説いたと説かれたとする
聞いた人はじーっと覚えて家に帰ったんですけど
2日  3日経つと あら  １２３と 5と 6
また 8も覚えていくつか忘れている
そうすると 自分が忘れたということを知ってるんです
自分が覚えてるものは一部だけだよと
だからもう一人知ってる人に会って
またこれを教えてもらったりすることはできるんです
だから仏教っていうのは大変大事な教えなんですよ
人間に実践的に自分の心を育てる方法を教えるものだから
医学よりとっても真剣なんです
医学ではもう中途半端で曖昧で十分です
別に体は自分に体力がある限りはもう死にませんだからね
お医者さんにはどうすることもできません
たとえ手術したっても
体に体力なければ治らないんです
それで昨日 なんとか医師不足
なんとかっていう記事を読んだところで
もう記事かテレビ番組を見てないんですけど
あの この仕事を辞めた方々にはもう一度教えるということで
だからみんな言うのは
ちょっと 1年  2年仕事を辞めただけで
また入ったら何もわからなくなるんだと
自分が仕事をした時は
やったことは今とんでもないことであると
もう禁止されているんだと
そこまで毎日変わってしまいますよ
医学分野は ということは
我々とんでもない危険な治療を受けているということになるんです
まあだから医学はなんか随分中途半端
曖昧でいいかもしれませんだけど
あの 仏教はそうじゃないんで
ものすごい真剣で精密に厳密に実践しなくちゃいけないんだ
自分の心の問題だから
肉体はどうしても捨てるものでしょうに
だから中身が大事 紙コップは大丈夫じゃないんですよ
紙コップに入れてるものが大事なんですよ
だから たとえ紙コップであっても
すごい高価なものを入れることもできます
それ使ってから紙コップの価値がないんです
だから 肉体について語る医学と心について語る仏教は
お釈迦様は自分も医者ですと言っているんだからね
同じことやってるんだと
病気治してるんだと だからものすごい精密に語ってるんです
だからちょっとだけでもアドバイス間違ったら困るんです
そういうことで 数字でしっかり止めてもらうんです
例えば道徳とか何だかいろんなこと言ってるでしょうね
じゃあいい人間にならなくちゃいけないんだとか
どこまでいい人間になるのかとはっきりしないでしょうね
何をすればいい人間か
もうこれまだわからないでしょうに
だから世間ではいい人間だったらこれぐらい項目だよということはどこにも言ってないんです
数字で仏教以外誰も言ってないんです
では良い人間とは何やというと
仏教の信者さんに お釈迦様は言うのは
あんたね この五戒だけ守ってくださいと ５
つだよと それで完全な良い人間になるんです
たった５つ そこで人が一つ破ってもわかってるんで
一つは破れてしまったと
またそれをやり直さなくちゃいけないんだと
だからそういう戒律項目いう時でも
まあこれこれこれまたいろいろありますよと
そういうふうに曖昧で言っちゃうと
まああんまりうまくいかないんですね
そういうわけで まあ数字で教えてもらうことも我々にとっては覚えやすい
まず何か忘れてしまったら忘れたんだと
この忘れたことを知ってるんですよ
普通は忘れたら忘れたんだから
忘れたっていうことをすぐ忘れるんです
ということで 物事を数字で分けてみたりするのは
頭にはいいことだと思います
数字で確定してある教えも
またこれ仏教のポイントなんですけど
説明するポイントによって
同じリストでも数字が変わったりする場合があります
例えばある教えがありまして
お釈迦様は 3つと言ったら
別なところで 6つと言うんです
別なところで 18だと言ったりもします
そうすると困るでしょう
いえ それはそれがなるほど
内容によってそういうことにもなるんだと
そう簡単に数字で数字でまとめて確定するものでもないとわかるんです
一番いい例っていうのは
この感覚 私はだいたい感覚は瞑想をアドバイスする場合は一つにするんです
体あるある感覚はすべて一つに
一で取ってくださいと
それは修行するために
しかし お釈迦様は 3つにするんです
時々感覚は 3つだよと
その場合は苦と楽と不苦不楽の感覚
で そういうお釈迦様は感覚は一つだけだとおっしゃるんです
その感覚の取り方なんですね
一つだけで取っちゃうと苦で取らなくちゃいけない
感覚が苦であると 生きることは苦であると
でも頭の悪い人間がいてね
苦じゃないでしょうと
そんなアホな話やと あまりにも頑固で
そういうことを言う場合はわかりました
じゃあ苦と楽と不苦不楽に分けてみてくださいと
それちょっと鈍感なんですよ
ものすごい敏感に感覚を感じると
全ての感覚 瞬間瞬間苦であるとわかるんです
だから 智慧の鋭い人に１で十分です
それほど鋭くない人にとってはこの感覚は 3つにするしかないんです
なおさら頭の悪い人々が来ると 3
つだけかと はい わかりました
目の感覚があるんだよと
それは苦 楽 不苦不楽で 3つだよと
耳の感覚あるでしょうと
そちらまた 3つだよと
舌の感覚 それと六根にかける3 です
18感覚なんです もっと頭がひどい人々が来たら
これっていうのはね あんたに過去にもあったでしょ？そういう感覚は
18種類は 今もあるでしょ
18は 将来も生まれるでしょうね
18掛ける3はいくらでしたっけ？ 54
それで 54感覚あるんだと
それでももっともうもっと頭が悪いんだったら
もっと考えなさい 世の中のこと
あなたに 54感覚があるんだと
他人にも同じ 54感覚があるんだと
どれぐらいですかと  108になるんです
それ 108感覚 前のそれなんです
だから感覚で一言でそういうふうに1であり 3
であり まあまあ6であり 18
でありとか もう分けて分けていくんです
それ一つの数字の勉強やり方なんです
それから因果法則の場合
学者 学者の方々は大変引っかかっているところは
因果法則っていうのはまた数字が変わるんです
学者の方々はそれわかって因果法則をわかってないんです
因果法則だからこそ数字が変わるんです
原因言ってることだから
主な原因いう場合も 主な原因とその環境にある原因も言う場合も
まだきめ細かく原因言う場合もありますけど
すべての原因すべてまとめて言うことは不可能なんです
例えば私はここに立っている
あらゆる原因で立っていますけど
すべて言うことはできないんですよ
地球の引力から体力のところから
できません だからまあ一つだけ
まあもうこちらで講演頼まれたんだから来て立ってさせてるんだと
だから原因は頼まれたことだと
原因一つでしょ だからってそれだけじゃないでしょうね
私は健康であることも必要でしょ
もし心臓発作でも起こしたならば来ないでしょうに
今日は だから健康であることも原因なんですけど
そこまでうるさく言わなくてもいいんです
だから因果法則の場合は
そういう風な この その
その話のテーマに合わせて因縁を言うんです
だから因縁は 2つだけ言う場合も
3つだけ言う場合も または並べてチェーンみたいに鎖みたいに言う場合も
12因縁言う場合も  6因縁もいろいろあるんです
時々 23因縁言ってる経典もあります
これが整理整頓できないんです
学者の方々に だから12因縁っていうのは後でできたものであると
もともとお釈迦様はそんなこと教えてないんだよとか
あれこれと言いたい放題のことを言うんです
言いたい放題のことを言うたびに
その人々は自分がこの研究分野に対しては見事な失格者であるということを発表しているだけなんです
だから その教えによって師匠体になってくると
お釈迦様ははっきり決めます
4つ終わり  5番目はなしと
で そういうふうな まあすべて数字なんですよ
まあ経典日本語訳ででも見てください
今日の経典も数字でいくんですよ
数字でまとめる方法を学ぶと
思考は明確になる 覚える能力が上がる
そういうことで 思考がすごく明確になる
覚えられます はい それでそのまあ余計な話終わり
で それ言ったのは 今日の経典にはもう数字がかなり絡んでいるんです
今日説明する経典はパッタカンマスッテン
意味は目的に達する 目的を完了するという意味なんですね
あの 学校でもエサイメントという言葉がありますね
大学でも学校でもね いろいろ学生さんに何かエサイメントするんですね
あれ なんて言いますか
日本語でもエサイメントでしょ
ん？宿題 えっ 課題とか何か仕事を与えるんですね
だからその人はそれをやらなくちゃいけないんですね
そこで 在家としてもアサインメント
在家として何をやるべきかと
大学のある研究室に入ったら
そこで次から次へとエサイメント
宿題みたいなものは与えられる
課題が与えられる それがやらなくちゃいけない
それをやらなかったら
学生としては失格になるんです
で この場合は在家としてのアサインメントという意味なんです
パッタカンマっていうのは
それやればもう完了  OK
卒業できます 在家生活は
であるところはアングッテルニカチャトゥッカニパートのパッタカンマワッグっていうお経は10 10 10
にして ワッグというセクションに切ってあるんです
もう経論も全部数字で遊んでいるんです
で それからこのアングッタルニカーナ
この 4番目のセクションも
あの またお経を五重 五重
五重にしているんです
これは 2番目の五重のセクションに入る 1番目の重
カテゴリーのまだ 1番目なんですね
はい その経典で出てくるのはアナータピンディカガハパティという人なんです
じゃあ この人のことをちょっと紹介しましょう
アナータピンディカ居士は釈尊の在家信者の長として尊敬されているんです
あの まあ仏教でもその人の能力
徳に合わせていろいろ位を与えたりするんです
で 別にこの名誉が欲しくているわけじゃなくて
あの 多大なことを貢献する人を讃嘆して
人間のためにそういうことをするんです
だから すごい貢献する人を無視しちゃうと
もう次の世代はどうなるんですかね
だから次の世代の人々はいろんな人々を大変褒め称えたりして
尊敬されたりするのを見たら
どういう人か どういうことをやっているのかと興味を持ったりして
自分たちも立派な人間になるようにする
ですから この仏教でも昔からいろんな位を与えるという
ことがあったんで アナータピンディカ居士が在家の人で
彼が在家信者のトップ第1位なんですね
私は第1という言葉を使わなかったのは
在家信者さんがもっと前もいたんですよ
そうすると初めの信者さんが第1になりますから
それはちょっとややこしいんです
初めてね ブッダに会った在家の人じゃないんです
随分後でブッダに出会ったんです
しかし それから彼がこの在家信者さんのリーダー長になってしまったんです
で お釈迦様はそう決めたんです
この人はみんなの第1で長であると
やはり王様もいましたよ
アナータピンディカさんがお釈迦様に出会う前に
ビムビサーラがお釈迦様に会ってるんです
ビムビサーラ様が大変仏教徒になって
そのほかにも悟りに悟りまで開いていたんです
しかし 長にはならなかったんですね
国王なのに で もっとお釈迦様の国も入っていた
コーサラ国の王様もお釈迦様も随分仲良しですけど
でしたけど 長ではないんです
かなり権力者でかなり危ない怖い人でしたけど
お釈迦さんは何のこともないんです
まあ友達として喋ったりはするんですけど
位はないんです 建て国王であっても
だから人が本当に持っている能力
徳に合わせて認めるという仏教の厳しいところなんです
釈尊に迷惑をかけてはならないと思った彼がブッダに質問をしないんですね
彼が考えたのは 私は在家で
このお釈迦様と弟子たちを助けてあげなくちゃいけない
お釈迦様が一生懸命人類に説法している
だから身の回りの面倒を見るのは私の仕事ではないかと
だから 自分の生きる目的はブッダを支えることにしちゃったんです
商売はほとんど第2にしたんですね
それで彼が考えたのは
お釈迦様は朝早くから夜遅くまで人の質問に答えて答えて答えて
毎日休みなく それでその私に行って質問するとね
とんでもないことであると
いうことで質問しない
でお布施をして お釈迦様に会って礼をして帰るんです
それでお釈迦様に会ったら
お釈迦様は何か喋ってあげるんです
まあ挨拶代わりに 彼の気持ちを知っている釈尊が彼に必要な教えを適切に語られたんです
だから何を喋るかというと
お釈迦様次第なんです
でもお釈迦様はよく読んでいるんだからね
心はね 本当に必要なことをその場その場で教えてあげるんです
大体在家生活すると もう気持ちいいことも
気持ち悪いことも 落ち込むことも
いろんなことあるんですよ
彼にとっても大変な波がありまして
全部財産なくなっちゃったこともあるんです
全部と言っても たくさん財産なくなりまして
それで本人がもう億万長者でしょうし
大富豪でしょうに お金がなくなるともう大変ですよ
その時もお釈迦様のお布施することだけはやめなかったんです
それだけではなく その時もお釈迦様が彼には落ち込まないようにすごく気をつけて
まあ褒め称えてするんで
あんたはね 苦しい時でもお布施するんだからね
まあそれこそ本物だよと
で そう褒めてくれると
自分がそこら辺の財産がなくても
まあお釈迦様に認められていて
有意義な人間であると
だからそんなことは誰が気にするのかと
金が全部なくなっても
自分が人間として宝物であると
知っていたんだから なんのことなく恐ろしい波から立ち上がったんです
すごい簡単に 常に明るく充実感を感じて生活できるように説法なさったんです
だからお釈迦様がその人だけは怒鳴ったりはなかったんです
他の人には何もわかりませんだけど
アナータピンディカ居士にはなんかすごいもう心明るくなる
あの教えだけほとんど教えてるんです
ある あんたは本当に立派な人間だよという意味になるように
まあなんとか教えるんです
で 今日の教えもそういうふうな教えなんですね
じゃあ 経典の中身に入ります
で 経典があのセクションごとにカットして紹介します